Hi, I'm Owen with FPW Media. I'm Adam from
FPW Media and we're here to talk about a
video we recently did called I AM APEX
for (Oregon based) Timber Products Company, specifically
their Ampine division and specifically
when they came to us about launching
their new product Apex which is a
composite panel product. We really worked
hard and kind of thought about how can
we make that visually interesting we
decided to have the story of the
production of one of these panels be
told from the perspective of the panel
so we shot the whole project on red we
shot on a red epic w and a red epic
dragon what was really interesting is
that the mills are really really really
dark like you can attest to this
insanely insanely dark so we shot most
of it at 3200 ISO I think yeah that
seems about right yeah which is nuts and
I mean it looked fantastic shot up
mostly on canons still glass l-series
lenses with a cinema lens here they're
thrown in I'd say it's an artistic
decision but it was also driven by
necessity but it was really awesome how
it worked out was the lighting you know
we knew that going in lighting was gonna
be a huge problem we've shot in a lot of
mills before so we decided to embrace
that lighting was gonna be a challenge
and actually physically show a lot of
our lights in the shots because in the
mills there's all sorts of different
lights that are different bulbs
different color temperatures and we knew
that we we're gonna have no control over
that yeah cuz it a lot of the times it
looks like what we're shooting is a spot
that needs to be examined anyway so it
could be a light that's spotted on there
for specific reason right so probably
one of the hardest shots I would say
from a safety perspective and just like
a planning perspective was our shots in
the furnished room where the dust comes
in and the furnish comes in to be made
into the board and the graded footage
you can't really tell but there it was
so dusty that when they were moving that
that is probably like a whiteout almost
I mean yeah Adam basically
with me and I don't actually know what
you were behind me so I had just I had
one hand on your safety vest just kind
of pulling you around making sure that
you didn't run into anything that if the
loader was coming at you we weren't too
close and then at one point your safety
glasses fell off and you must have just
been filming blindness and it basically
was I mean it was like I kind of knew
where I could see where the loader was
and I could kind of see what the camera
but I was just basically imagining the
framing because I couldn't even see the
screen because the screen got completely
covered over a dust at one point and so
we were just but it turned out really
well yeah and then as soon as it was
over as soon as it take was over it'd be
us running out putting the camera on on
an on the stand and then just I mean
blowing it off like crazy Oh No weird
Adam go sitting here with Jake our
senior editor at fbw media to talk about
the post-production process on ima fix
Jake you want to kind of take us through
our last product shot where we dip back
into the narrative yeah and sometimes
it's great because that one was actually
really easy that was kind of a move born
out of the camera movement and then all
I had to do was really dip to black
there and just pay close attention to
where we were making the actual cut in
both of those when we kind of threw a
curveball and that one a little bit
because that part of the project wasn't
shot until almost the whole edit was
done I would say yeah so you had this
kind of gaping hole for most of the Edit
of where those product shots were
supposedly connected and those were also
kind of fun because we had a lot of
visual effects to cover things that we
couldn't get in camera so you added more
fire more fire in the studio it's kind
of hard to not light things on fire
right right and then on the moisture
scene did you add more a couple layers
in front or how did I added some layers
of smoke in front and then I masked out
the actual piece and added a couple
behind it to give it that sense of depth
that it has all in all I think it's one
of the projects that I'm most proud of
and we had a blast film in it if anybody
has any questions about the production
or the gear we use or anything like that
please reach out to us
and make sure to watch the video in full
thanks for watching
my name is Jack Marchetti I'm a writer
director and I'm here to talk to you
about the camera I chose to use on my
last film which was also my first film
the evolution of hnx music purchaser the
camera we shot on was a red epic we shot
in 5k and we used red Pro prime lenses I
will preface my remarks right now by
saying that if you know a lot about
lenses a lot about cameras
you're like a camera hobbyist and you
know a ton about them and things along
those lines this is not the video for
you this is more for people like myself
from two years ago who you know first
time director hadn't really been on a
set before never really messed around
with cameras and didn't really know a
thing or two about the difference
between a red or an Alexa or what we can
do with the DSLR even shooting out an
iPhone or aspect ratios and things along
those lines so like I said we decided to
shoot with a red epic one of the reasons
why I wanted to shoot on a red epic was
I had heard about it I knew that David
Fincher used them I like the look of
David Fincher films and so I wanted my
film to look like a movie we all talked
about the film look and what that is and
I just thought you know you need the
camera to do that and it turns out it's
not really the camera that determines
the film look it helps but it's about
frame selection it's about the lenses
it's about the story and if you properly
frame something in your iPhone it's
gonna look like a movie I kind of want
to talk to you about the benefits of
shooting on a red epic like I said we
shot 5k which is a huge amount of
resolution it's massive and the big
benefit of doing that that I found was
we were able to reframe some shots in
post-production I don't recommend doing
this you should frame correctly on set
you should have your shot list all set
out which we did however when we got
into posts there were a few shots that
we just ran out of time on
when you look back at them you know a
month later they just didn't look right
this shot here we were running out of
time this was our last night of shooting
I think we had about ten minutes left
and this was the last thing we did and
we set up the camera in the rear window
passenger side window and shot this and
it's it's a very simple thing
however this right here is the exact
same shot we're just punched in about
200% so this is the actual thing we shot
which is fine but I wanted to punch in a
little bit on him for a close-up and
there's the close-up it's the exact same
shot it's just done in post-production
if you were to do this correctly on set
with the proper lenses the background
probably would have looked a little bit
differently but at the end of the day
like I said who cares we did this again
this shot right here so this is where
this is the altered read this is the
reframe shot this right here is the what
we actually shot this is us punched in
and we're punched in I think maybe a
hundred two hundred percent while still
maintaining 1080p we also did this
similar approach on this shot now I'll
admit right now that this is just poorly
framed I don't actually have an example
of the wide shot that we started from in
the film if we were planning on shooting
it like this we would have probably
changed it though the camera angle
changed the lenses and it would have
looked a lot differently but again in
post you you know when we shooting at
such high res your label able to mess
around with things like that
another thing that that's a benefit that
you can't get on let's say view shot on
an iPhone or something like that if you
were going that low-tech you're not
gonna be able to get something like this
does see how the background is all out
of focus it's called a shallow depth of
field and you need a longer lens to pull
this off and so another benefit that I
don't really have a before-and-after to
show you but when you
such high resolution you are able to if
you have a color is not bored they have
almost an unlimited ability to
manipulate the image that you've created
because you've provided them with so
much detail each frame of a red epic is
the equivalent of shooting I think like
a fourteen point four megapixel still
shot so even an enormous amount of data
to manipulate and work with so I didn't
really find anything negative about
working with a red I'd heard that
they're very loud and we were shooting
in some places that were actually open
for business like a record store and I
was really worried about this thing
sounding like a hairdryer and put it
actually you know I didn't really have
any we didn't have any problems with
that at all one thing we did run into
was we wanted to use a movie stabilizer
however there's a weight limit on that
and our red with the red pro prime
lenses would have exceeded the weight
limit so we weren't able to use the movi
if I could go back two years to when we
shot the film I would probably tell my
more inexperienced self to not get hung
up on the camera I got really set on we
needed to use a pro grade camera
professional camera and I hammered that
point home but then you get into editing
and you realize that you know maybe
you're missing story or maybe the sound
didn't work out or whatever you're not
at all worried about what camera used or
things along those lines at least I was
and when we were in the editing Bay
putting everything together the last
thing I was worried about was the camera
I was more worried about like did we did
we get enough coverage of certain scenes
which we didn't did the story make sense
we had professional sound onset so the
sound was great and I would say if you
if you're putting your budget together
and you have money for sound or money
for the camera shoot on your iPhone and
pay someone to record sound the sound is
going to make your film if your movie
looks like crap what sounds great people
are gonna assume it looks like crap
because you wanted it to look like crap
as an aesthetic reason
if it looks amazing and sounds terrible
people are just gonna assume you are no good
and you have no idea what you're doing
and no one's gonna think oh that was
shot on a red epic or an Alexa look at
those skin tones no one's gonna give a
fuck they just aren't and so in
conclusion I would definitely use a rat
epic again I'd have no problem with it
again I would just say that I would not
get hung up on the camera on my next
project if my DP says look let's shoot
on an iPhone let's shoot on a 5d or a 7d
or whatever let's shoot on an Alexa I
don't really care anymore
because to me the camera doesn't really
matter and if I were to leave you with
anything and hopefully you come away
with anything from this just realize the
camera really doesn't matter does it do
they have benefits absolutely but if you
frame correctly like correctly you still
delight correctly and have it sound well
the camera will be the absolute least of
your worth. Hi I'm Pipas Forjaz.
I'm Mozambican DOP I want to talk to you
about the look and feel and the
equipment we're gonna use for our first
feature film RESGATE for me as the dop
telling the story visually is the most
important part the movie will be a
mixture of different styles depending on
the pace and mood of each sequence I
haven't researched a specific look what
I've done for many years now is watch
many many movies and learn from each we
will not stick to a specific visual
style or even lighting style throughout
the movie depending on the sequence we
will shoot handheld or in a serene and
gravity one on legs or on a dolly we
will use all the equipment we have at
our disposal to tell as well as we can
our story and make a compelling film to
watch I feel that a movie does not have
to follow a single visual style
throughout it has to use the style each
sequence calls for as for which camera
I'm going to use well let me tell you
how I got to my decision I used to shoot
on many of different cameras when I
started film school in Columbia College
Chicago in the early
1990s we should shoot on 16 millimeter
black-and-white film we use Bolex
cameras to roll up the the ones that you
wind up then I used r isse s ARS and CP
16 declares many different cameras when
I returned to Mozambique in 1995 there
was no film cameras here so I had to
shoot on whatever I got my hands on and
whatever the budgets could afford all
video cameras for sure but during that
time I longed for a camera that would
give me the look and feel of the film
cameras I had shot with at school in
2007 I had the pleasure of shooting
again on film on a commercial I shot in
South Africa and what the difference
that was it was really just going back
in time in 2005 I had read about Jim
Jannard and his red dream on the
internet I followed him until the red
one was launched in 2007 but I just
didn't have the cash to put down the
downpayment it was $1000 at that time I
just didn't have that money and well
actually maybe I had $1000 but didn't
have the the rest to pay the the camera
so I just I just looked and I couldn't
buy it but anyway I worked for 2 years
and in 2009 I had saved enough money to
buy my first red one and I just closed
my eyes and threw the money at the red
one and I bought the red one and I
didn't even have lenses for it if I
remember correctly I just had that one
that camera and I had a lens that I had
for my old CP 16 that I bought from film
school and I bought an adapter and I
used it with a red one but shooting on a
on a 16 millimeter lens on the red one
was not very much it wasn't very much
fun when we shot our first film short
film in 2009 we went to South Africa and
rented some very nice vintage designs
lenses and those were real nice lenses
to shoot on then I bought the
second-hand a red zoom
and 18 to 50 lens and I remember
shooting a whole movie on that one lens
from was it was strange to shoot on one
lens the whole movie because going from
18 to 50 sometimes you want to go longer
so what dude I used to do if I reach the
50 millimeter mark on the lens and I
still not had reached my the size I
needed I would change the setting on the
red one and go for example from 4 K to 3
K and that would make it a longer lens
and if I wanted a longer lens I'll go
down to 2 K and I have a longer lens it
was fake but I still was able to shoot
all movie if you watch the movie you
can't really figure out that I used
different the same lens to shoot the
whole movie not the best thing to do but
when you don't have the money it just
ends up working out 2 K in 2009 in 2010
was still a very good size to shoot on
and look so much better than HD then or
now as time passed I saved more money
and I was able to buy my first set of
prime lenses from red I got the 18
millimeter the 25 the 30 585 the 5100
and a beautiful beautiful 300 millimeter
lens that I really liked anyway I
haven't really shot with another camera
ever since
well not exactly I've upgraded the red
one from the red one to red 1m X and
then from the MX to the epic and then
from the epic to the dragon and from the
dragon to the weapon so it's been an
evolution the cameras kept on getting
better and better and better and yet
even today when I shoot on the net and
the MX no old MX I'm surprised how good
it looks
so ever since 2009 I haven't had really
had a choice I decided shot on red for
me the strengths and weaknesses of the
rebbe weapon well let me start with the
strengths right off the bat raw is the
most important part of red then the size
of the frame
I think 6k the size of the our 3d files
the latitude of the sensor and now the
size of the camera
in 2009 the red one was a monster it was
really big it was heavy wasn't it was a
difficult camera to shoot on just if you
wanted to put it on your shoulder you
know it was heavy
now the the weapon is so much smaller
and lighter I love it and ultimately the
ability to use PL glass and changing
lens mounts and put in Econ lenses and
Canon lenses it's got so many different
strengths as for weaknesses the old red
one for me had four main weaknesses its
size its weight the race at which it ate
up the batteries it was just
unbelievably fast at finishing batteries
and the time it took to boot up I
remember it used to take two minutes
something to it just seemed like it took
ages but it did give a pretty picture
and it was when it was upgraded to the
MX it looked even better I actually
pulled out my red one MX the other day
and did a two camera set up with red one
MX and the weapons side-by-side and they
cut perfectly well together no problems
the weaknesses of the weapon I really
can't say there's a lot of weaknesses
it's a really great camera could have
maybe a bit more battery life maybe I
even faster boot up but I can't really
complain maybe when I try a better
camera better camera from red then I'll
see the differences but for now they
sound very nice in 2016 I invested in a
new set of shield lenses from Duclos in
LA I've been shooting on the shins for
the last few months for me one big
advances is that they're much much
lighter and smaller than the parade
Prime's the red Prime's are heavy and
they big and they're not the same size
and they've got a heavy focus ring and
anyway the the
jeans are much nicer they've got a much
nicer focus ring
I mean mechanically they seem to flow
much better smoother but they do breathe
a bit more than I read the red primes
when you do react focusing from for me
I'll have to live with that but I'll
have to save up to buy a like a vintage
set of Zeiss lenses or or the like semi
looks lenses but that that that will be
later that's a dream but as I figure out
dreams from my experience do seem to
come true especially when you work hard
for them to come true well I hope you
had an interesting time listening to me
speak about what I love doing hi I'm
Dana Brower and I'm the director of the
new short film signing out
written by Adriana Leonard and Jenna
Mitch now the film is about two women
who still haven't recovered from the end
of their romantic relationship with each
other and they unknowingly find
themselves in the same therapists office
years later in a 4-step come to terms is
what happened so I'm here today to talk
to you about the camera that we use to
get the look that we wanted for this
film so for the look of this film
Madelyn burger our DP and I talked a lot
about really making sure that the two
segments of the film the past versus the
present present being what's in the
therapy room past being in the
flashbacks we wanted to make sure that
they felt different but they still felt
like they were part of the same story
so Madelyn and I worked on making sure
that the season the therapy office
present day were more sterile clean less
contrast less saturation and when we did
have camera movement it we put it on a
dolly
so the movement was very controlled
whereas the flashbacks the memories when
these girls are remembering the happy
in their relationship there's a lot of
movement we shot handheld people so shot
Ronin and there was a lot more
saturation higher contrast and just
generally more vibrant so for this
project Madeline and I decided to shoot
red dragon
Madeline is an Alexa girl but
unfortunately the budget couldn't afford
Alexa so a lot of the decisions that we
made for this were based on budget that
camera Deb Madeline and I decided to go
with for this was the red dragon the red
dragon compared to other Reds handle
skin tones better and it's also pretty
light so it was light enough to go on a
run in and they used handheld without
anybody's back breaking the large sensor
also allows you to shoot at a high
resolution
and then downsize to reduce noise which
leads me into some of the weaknesses of
shooting red red cameras are noisy also
if you shoot at a low ISO lower than
native it actually affects your exposure
curve so it can make the highlights fly
off out of nowhere so to remedy this
Madeline and our awesome awesome camera
team they shot at the skin tones
highlight olp F around 400 ISO which
allowed them to control the highlights a
little bit more and keep them a bit more
contained it's not perfect I know
Madeline has some words to say about
this issue but ultimately it does not
impact the look of our film at all and
I'm still very very happy with the look
that we have so in addition to shooting
and the red dragon we actually used ZF
prime lenses for this which was not our
original intention Madeline and I were
really committed to shooting on
SuperSpeed as if we could afford it and
we found this share grid listing for red
dragon 5 super speed lenses the package
also had the wireless video village also
monitor is an easy rig and many other
components that would have been very
expensive to rent independently but our
prep day originally scheduled for a few
days before the shoot had to be pushed
back to the day before the shoot and
when Madeline and the team
they're the super speeds that were
advertised and the listing were actually
ZF primes so at that point we didn't
have the time or the money to go find
something else that's what we had so the
downside to shooting on these lenses is
that ZF bronzer still lenses and it can
affect the way you pull focus that being
said our first AC Edward Bellamy very
talented guy he was able to make it work
and so was Madeline and the rest of the
camera team but despite it not being
exactly what we wanted
I'm still very very happy with the look
of the film Madeline his to maybe would
have been better if we had super speeds
maybe not it's always in filmmakers
heads if I had this light but this
camera maybe it would be better but this
film signing out really is a testament
to the power of independent filmmaking
and the less-is-more
concept we really were only able to rent
exactly what we needed so I'm forced
Madeline and her team to really only use
lights and equipment if we needed it and
for this project that helped us get the
look that we wanted again we wanted it
to feel very real we didn't want to
glamorize the flashbacks or the memories
at all we wanted everything to feel very
true and because we didn't have a lot of
lights it feels that way it doesn't feel
like a big studio production it feels
more intimate so ultimately even though
with more money maybe we would have
rented more lights had an HMI on set the
fact that we didn't have a ton of lights
helped us actually maybe you get closer
to the look that we wanted hey guys my
name is Pascal Paula I'm the movie
director of on the horizon and today I'm
gonna talk to you about my process using
the red dragon camera under Eisen came
from a very ambitious vision the goal
was to shoot something around the world
we shot in France and Utah and it was no
crew it was me my son guy an assistant I
wanted to break the barriers about what
can we do with absolutely nothing and
have a high quality product so that's
what I was trying to accomplish and then
the big question was what camera can I
use
because nowadays anything can be shot
with absolutely everything we can use a
high phone DSLR whatever so my big my
big concern was I don't want to mess it
up I want to make sure that I can go
quick I can shoot fast I can walk fast
that there's no big preparation I just
want to shoot and make sure that the big
quality is there so I was debating what
camera do I use so I've chosen and I was
debating for months to just trying to
find the best camera possible so Indian
I chose the red dragon was it the best
camera for the job yes and no yes
because first it was the price that's
what I wanted to accomplish first what
can I get with my budget for my feature
film because the whole thing was shot
with $85,000 so the K I didn't want to
spend too much money on the gear but at
the same time I wanted to make sure that
the quality was there so what I did is
that I was finding doing research to
make sure that the look that I wanted
was was possible so with the red dragon
the beauty of it is that first it was
the money I had an amazing sponsor in
Montreal call post-modern and they gave
me for a very cheap price they give me
the camera for the month it was a red
dragon 66k everything was shot in 6 K
but finish in 4k and delivered in HD
some platform is 4k so after a lot of
debate I was doing the pros and con and
that camera allowed me to make sure
first it was a row so the beauty of Rob
was that I can shoot anywhere and if I
mess it up I can fix in post because
everything if you guys sort of filmed it
was all shot almost outside natural
location natural lighting so I needed I
needed the options to make sure that I
can fix everything in post I didn't want
to be a crutches but I wanted to make
sure that it was I wanted to make sure
that at least it was a tool that I can
lean on if I need to so so yeah that
camera the the image is absolutely
stunning you you cannot go wrong with
that camera it's one of the best in the
world but the other camera that I was
debating was the Sony because I know
that everything was about to shoot and
light so the dasoni cannot be beat even
the cannons I was doing I was debating
do I go na na compressed footage
something super small compared to the
red that I had to make it as a DSLR a
little bit so everything was shot with
one end o my lands and the better reason
so it was it was almost 20 pounds total
so after one month its it can be a kind
of a burden compared to small DSLR it
can shouldn't fast way easier so you
need to be in shape that's for sure so
Indiana I just wanted to make I think
the the raw aspect of it just one over
everything the funny thing is that I
never shot with the red camera like
never it was the first time on set that
I've used it I didn't know anything
about it I've read online check videos
on YouTube and I was just like let's go
jump because in the end I think it's
always kind of the same thing you just
you know you can have any kind of camera
at the N is you need to be great you
need to be able to get the image out of
any kind of camera the it's it's all
about yourself it's you know that's what
for me it was important to research the
location that fit my style so for me I
love to shoot outside beautiful location
everything needs to be puppy eye and
that's that's what I love the most
so I know with the red camera was able
to get amazing dynamic range the Ruff
footage that after that when it's time
to do the color correction that I did
with postmodern again it was just
amazing with the quality that you were
able to achieve it was I thought it was
kind of good about grading but now I
realized that I suck when you work with
professionally it changes everything
what make me go to the red camera was
price-wise it was the quality and at the
end it was just like price-wise it
stupid to say but Indiana be any kind of
camera can do the same thing I think yes
maybe in the color grading section you
can see a big difference because it's
not wrong but uh but yeah I wanted to
make sure that this film was the best
that I can shoot and if there's any kind
of mistakes I can and in the end I
didn't do a lot of mistakes I was super
lucky about that
not another lot of problem
and sometime near Vienna had probably
with the sensor for some reason it
started to glitch like crazy and it was
like the last day of my shoot after 23
and 24 day the sensor completely messed
up so I was freaking out like crazy so I
had a camera in backup just in case and
it was a Panasonic gh4 that I'm still
using today and it's a great camera but
it's completely in a whole different
ballgame compared to red I'm not a big
fan it's that it's great it does a
beautiful 4k images but there's a one or
two scene in the film that I'm using the
GA the gh4 but I don't know just someone
left use that camera so and then the
next thing how was the suni was a big
big big factor that I wanted to go
because of low light a lot of at least
after the film is shot in low light and
I know Reds
kind of suck and look light but I was
super surprised of the quality that you
can achieve in low light there's a big
nightclub scene with there's lasers and
flashes of light and everything is blue
it came out beautifully of course I had
to tone it down with with the noise
reduction a little bit but mostly what
you see in the film
it's is the quality itself a lot of
people asking me what type of lens that
I've used for the film and everything
was shot what I think is the best lens
that you can have I didn't knew I didn't
use cine lens I never used with another
word with those kind of lenses but it
was shot with the Canon 24 to 105 l
series I think is the most versatile
best lens possible stable design it's a
lens that has stabilization in it and I
think it's just it's just a dream come
true you don't have to waste time to
switch to because just that it cuts the
time of your shooting just always to
stop stop production change the gear
change the lens do testing so at least
for me when I should I love to make it
as a documentary so I need to shoot fast
I need to zoom in you don't lose time
you play with the actors you try stuff
and just for example the scene that
you're seeing behind me it was just
improv let's go with it and we save at
least one hour just because I could walk
away with the actors and play with them
just you go from a 24 millimeters to a
105 it stabilized and I think it's still
the best lines for probably 10 years
that the only lens that I've worked with
and even in low-light at one point I use
a 24 millimeter 1.4 because I needed a
lot of low-light but other than that
everything was shot with a 24 to 105 I
think is the best sense if you need one
lens this advanced a lot of research was
planning to the film just location wise
because I wanted to make sure that each
shot each location was stunning was pure
breathtaking that looked different and
looked like film that's what's the main
kind the main thing to make sure that
everything is perfect so that after that
a camera can do its job and just capture
everything and the beauty with the red
dragon is that everything that you shoot
is just so stunning with the dynamic
range I think it's almost 17 with the
red dragon and you're just being able to
capture all those details in the clouds
and you just maintain all those
beautiful details that you sometime with
other cameras you can lose one detail
that I would say the big tip for how to
shoot with red that's what I've learned
and I've learned had a little bit too
late
but I think it's just what you need to
do is that you make sure that the
exposure it's always at 800 you don't
you don't need to go back because it's
wrong you don't need to bring it to 250
or 400 whatever I would suggest you
expose everything at 800 and you make
sure that your Instagram it's always in
the middle just a little bit going to
the eye light because once you're in
that sweet spot then you can bring
everything down you can bring it to 600
500 400 whatever and you're gonna have
the most amazing details and you have
options to play with because if you
start let's say at 800 but you expose
too low then you're screwed because
after that you have to crank it and it's
not gonna be as great so make sure that
800 ISO you make sure that you always in
your middle of I of the Instagram are
just a little bit towards the eye light
just that little trick seriously is
gonna save you so much work and you're
gonna have the best possible result
before the project I've asked
other filmmakers what was their
experience with the red and a lot of
people were seeing the same thing it
sucks in a little light it sucks in a
low light and like I said I think it was
pretty amazing what you can achieve in
low-light again you need to make sure
that you find location that there's
lights as an Indian at least it can be
spotlight of the street it can be car
that can be anything but if you have
some kind of source around it you get it
good the most important part of my
decision to choose the red Indian was
raw it was the amazing dynamic range and
quality of the images price-wise because
I had a sponsor so that made a huge huge
difference and then it was just the
overall quality for me it was kind of a
trip of what it is the feeling to work
with the red camera how is it gonna come
out is it gonna be beautiful is it gonna
be great and overall even if I had some
glitch with the sensor at the end it was
just an amazing blast and it's always
fun or just you you shoot some stuff you
think it's gonna be great but it's when
you start to do the color correction or
you see some professional to do that
with your footage and you see it on a
big screen
that's where it blows your - oh yeah
just make sure that there's so many
camera right now that the good job so
just pick what you feel is gonna help
you the most with the project because
any kind of quality any kind of camera
is gonna give you the best quality
possible so at the end is just make sure
that you're just at he's with the camera
for me it was - like a DSLR so I was
super at ease of course it's heavy but
once you get that rig the hang of it
you're gonna be fine it's just you're
gonna be able to set it out like I said
one big tip that I would suggest to
people is that make sure you work with
someone who knows exactly how to grade
your images that's day and night that's
gonna kill it or make your project I was
so shocked and surprised to see
professional tweaked my images to do
something completely amazing
and it's just a collaborating effort
that you see that you're in the room and
you see your images and then you play
with the colors you test on stuff
everything was done in resolve at the
past modern facility and but we didn't
do any kind of lot or stuff
like that it was just pure curve and
tweak and little recipe that they were
doing but as you can see everything is
super puppy I love when it's blast so I
make sure that all my location represent
my cell that I was doing I didn't buy
any lens for this like everything was
rendered up the the 24-105 I got that
lens and the buy the rest I rented it
everywhere but you can you can make an
amazing film and have if you have a
connection to please bring all those
gears that's where you can cut down if
you have sponsors if you have connection
you don't need a lot of stuff that's
what I've learned you don't need a for
me all my I've done I've been doing this
for 10 years and I never really on gears
it was just the simplistic way I can
shoot and I think that's the premier
please when you shoot like a documentary
light fast quick that's where you can be
way more creative because the look is
gonna be great but then after that you
have the time to play with the actors to
crew to create something super amazing
and but once you have the location the
world that you want to create then you
can bring any kind of camera and you may
he's gonna make it pop that's for sure
the whole film was it is on Adobe
Premiere I thought that'd be the process
of just bringing all the red footage
into the air appear with flawlessness it
was just it was super easy it was as
soon as you put it in your dragging it
to your Timeline it pops its words
natively and then after that you just
start editing I didn't do any kind of
proxies I just did the 6k footage right
away and then at the end if you have and
I have the latest Mac Brewer the iMac
and it worked perfectly so you don't
need the biggest 7,000 10,000 computer
because I did it trust me I bought the
ten thousand dollar computer and I sold
it because I thought it was pure crap
and then I went back to iMac and it
worked flawlessly so just it'll be
premiere was just the best friend of red
I think they just completely complement
each other perfectly the one thing that
was super surprised about is that when
you shoot with red the image quality
it's so filmic and that was another big
factor that I was debating between the
Sony f55 and the red dragon
and I was testing but I was seeing
footage online and I love how clean and
digital it was from the SUNY and it was
a good thing and a bad thing because I
wanted to have this kind of a film look
and but with the red I don't know it was
just there's just something so filming
about it that it's maybe less clean or
less digital that the Sony and I think
that's a good thing because you want to
be I'm not a purist that I want to do
film and stuff like that for me I love
digital but the sweet the problem I
think is just it's too video ish you
know I mean so with the red I think it's
just almost look like filming us it's
almost identical I think so yeah
but thank you so this is my experience
with the red camera Iowa I recommend it
to everyone I just bought it so I think
it's it's a great camera I want to work
with that process that kind of a culture
of red and once you're of course there's
gonna be other camera that's gonna come
out that's probably gonna be freaking
amazing but in the end just take any
tool that you want just go out there
shoes find amazing location create great
character stories and go for it you know
don't depend on your gear we're sewing
mm almost 17 we're just talking about
gear Eve your gear but focus on the
story focus of the world is the mood
that you want to create and that's way
more important than any kind of gear
that you can accomplish so find what you
love find a tool that really helps you
to be creative that inspires you because
I've experienced that there's some tools
that can kill your creativity and I
think the gh4 did that for me I didn't
like at all that camera and I'm selling
it right now so but with the red and
when I took it I wanted to create I
don't know there's just some kind of
energy something about camera that just
connect with you so once you find that
tool go outside have fun shoot do
whatever you want and just have fun guys
and just shoot the most amazing freakin
project thank you the first red gig I
ever got I can tell the story now
because it's yours later but the first
time I ever shot with the red camera I
did not ever have any experience of the
red camera
point one of the key questions that they
ask you is have you ever shot with the
red before and just came out like a few
weeks before that I was like oh yeah of
course you know I shot with it numerous
times like music videos and blue I just
had to make up something because and
then immediately after that I was
googling the instruction manual and I
showed up to set the next day I even
called my professors is like have you
guys ever got a hand your hands under
red camera like at Miami they're like I
don't even know what you're talking
about right now because it was so new
and I was like oh crap I'm gonna I'm in
over my head and I got so nervous so I
just took I got so nervous that I over
prepared so I went and I read the entire
manual front to back like four times at
night I had notes taken I had like every
possible problem that we could have come
up with I looked on forums and see what
people were having overheating problems
how you fix that blah blah blah I show
up to set the next day and I knew more
about the camera than the guy who owned
it and I was like okay I'm fine and then
the film turned out really cool it was a
little short film called colony directed
by a friend of mine kevin hamid ani
sorry Kevin I don't think I've ever told
you this story before but I didn't know
how to use a direct camera before colony
and I ended up ultimately shooting that
guy's feature film junk which is now out
on DVD so a little bit of playing the
game I mean that's a Hollywood you know
story right there like that's the kind
of stuff I heard growing up and that's
this kinda stuff I learned from reading
rubber every guys's book or you just
kind of like you know out here there's
no rules you can kind of make your own
rules
back in 2007 the red one came out I was
on the waiting list back you know 2006
we were out of nab and it was like okay
put your name on the waiting list put a
thousand dollars in deposit and you're
gonna wait for a camera that has 4k
resolution it sounds a bit unknown but
we did you know I was part of that first
thousand that was on the waiting list
and in 2007 on that fall they finally
released the first 25 cameras or
something like that and we got to shoot
out on the Bonneville Salt Flats
on a short film call you uni we were
working with red number 19 you know out
there and we did a short film on the red
camera
those are those early days but yeah in
2008 we got one of the red cameras and
then went out and shot this project out
of Burning Man
so you purchased the camera you put the
deposit down and you purchased it yeah
yeah we were red number nine and eight
and so from the behind the scenes
footage that I watched which is
absolutely beautiful by the way it shows
that you've protected the camera with
like plastic because of these whiteout
days can you tell us what was involved
what's a whiteout day why protect it
like that yeah well I mean you want to
protect any kind of camera out there the
dust storms will just happen and there's
40 mile an hour winds and the dust is
not like any dust you've ever
experienced
it's alkaline dry lakebed dust I mean
it's not sand it's not dirt it's it's a
very sticky material and so yeah it gets
on your fingers and your fingers touch
things and all of a sudden you have it
on your lenses and on your camera and so
yeah we we ended up gaff taping over a
bunch of the camera ports and then we
had a protective plastic bag that
sometimes we'd throw the camera into if
it was like complete whiteout but yeah
this stuff this stuff blows into cracks
you didn't know existed the dust out
there and if it gets in those cracks is
that what can be done to fix it or
nothing can be done it's the balance of
like are you gonna take a camera out
there and protect it the whole time and
not get that much access to your camera
or you're gonna go out there with a
camera and just say well it's just a
camera I can replace it it's a fine
balance and and we had three red cameras
out there we had 10 little pocket HD
cameras out there and we had a couple
digital SLRs shooting time-lapse and we
did our best we had the digital SLR
covered as best we could we have the
small pocket cameras kinda not protected
but the red cameras were kind of
protected it's tough I was out there
shooting a couple years later back in
2010 and 2011 for another project and
destroyed the can
and destroyed the red so it's it's an
expensive piece of gear to have to deal
with how did that happen
it was just dust I think you know it
gets inside and even though the Reds are
incredibly protected especially now with
a new epoch cameras they're just
workhorses I mean beef they these things
have been in conditions like Burning Man
that are just unbelievable
crazy temperatures freezing temperatures
altitude everything they're just amazing
and I think you know I just push it to
the limits and we had to replace I think
one of the processing boards inside got
wrecked so so with the three red cameras
that you took out there were they all
purchased or you rented two of them
purchased one um basically I worked with
other filmmakers my friend clay a new
york-based filmmaker came out with his
camera and then another guy came out
with his so we had we had three total
who can you tell us the camera that you
purchased what was it again I was a red
scarlet okay and what were the major
factors in you purchasing that camera
and why didn't you rent it versus just
outright buying it mm-hmm um I think
it's a really tough question for people
to I think you know when you make those
decisions you don't necessarily know at
the time whether it's the right or the
wrong decision you just sort of have to
go off of a sense and in a projection of
what you're gonna be working on the
reason that I liked the red was I felt
it did a lot of things in the camera
that other cameras needed you needed to
attach a lot of doodads to you know
whether if you wanted to get 4k on
another camera you have to attach an
external recorder normally if you want
to record to compress raw that's not
even an option for most of these other
cameras even though red has been doing
it now for five years so I felt like it
was something that once they were
getting supported by editing systems so
you can just drag in our 3d files to the
timeline and cut natively it was
something that gave you a lot of
flexibility for high-end projects
something that you could go shoot a
feature on but also something that you
could
use you know as a compact package to go
film an interview you know so the first
Attila T of the tool was what made me
think I'm comfortable investing in this
because it it goes in different
directions whereas I think some of the
other cameras are more specialized in
their limitations hold you back from
certain productions but you know the
camera market is changing I don't know
that I'll be shooting on a read forever
you don't know what's coming out around
the corner you know but thankfully most
of these professional tools hold their
value decently so when you're selling or
you know red has an upgrade program so
just just the the idea that it's gonna
last you for a number of years is the
the calculation for me is is thinking
about how much use can I get out of this
and for how long and was that also what
factored into you purchasing it rather
than renting it's kind of like leasing a
car versus buying it did you know that
there'll be additional things I'll want
to shoot with it this is not the last
time I'm going to use this or I think as
indie filmmakers we have this romantic
idea that if you own the equipment
you're not going to be held back from
having an idea and going and shooting or
something for no money with your friends
and getting it in the can because you
already spent the money on the camera so
it's not costing you anything to go make
this movie right and there's nothing
wrong with that idea and I certainly
share that myself and and you know I
think that's that's kind of like the the
calculation behind buying something
because typically if you're only gonna
rent you know for me I'm not doing
freelance work I'm working on my own
projects and so it takes me a lot of
time to write and go through
pre-production and do that I'm not going
to be using the camera that many days
out of the year but I do like the idea
that oh I
we can go make this thing with with the
equipment we have as opposed to like
setting up a budget and getting
production insurance and getting rentals
and having to build that whole thing
every
you go shoot something because we're
shooting two cameras two reds and we
actually had a third red as a backup
which came from our investors in
Nebraska who are farmers but they had
their own red camera because crop
circles yeah and well they even nephew
use it filmmakers say oh the camera oh
so we had that as a backup you know cuz
these things go down so we would use the
body food at different times but uh so
Nancy and I would be if the two monitors
and and then have two different
operators and she was very good at sort
of managing how they would go so they
weren't shooting into each other down
the barrel of each other which was I was
very impressed with you know so we
always had great usable footage from
both cameras but I think the you know
the challenge because you know no matter
how good things are there are always
challenges was you know it took a long
time to light you know because it was
largely an inexperienced crew and Nancy
likes her lights and there were a lot of
them so it took us a few days to kind of
find a rhythm where we could where I
think Nancy and I together realized you
know the big lighting changes we're
going to take a long time we didn't want
them to what they did and that was
frustrating for the action is
frustrating for me as a director and it
slowed down our days but what didn't
take a long time were camera changes so
a change of a dolly move or you know
change of a you know if you're using a
zoom you just zoom in you get a hold of
you and you go from two shot to one shot
those kinds of little changes are
changing the focus mark you know so
those could be done you know very
quickly between takes but a lot of times
what we could do is Josh who's our first
AC on one of the cameras had a remote
control control for the red I don't know
what it's called but you know control
focus and zoom and everything even
sometimes during a take I would whisper
to him right now I know Nancy would
whisper to him you know let's you know
let's nudge in a little bit let's do a
slow zoom here we did a fair number of
slow zooms
the movie and and we could do that you
know without the camera operators even
knowing it in the middle of a shot and
they'd be like what and but it was great
it was it was it was nice to be able to
do that and to have that option you know
part of it was that we shot on 4k and we
finished in 2k which I don't really know
what that means except for is bigger
than two and that's what counts because
what that meant was that I knew that in
post-production we would be we would
have the option to zoom in and basically
keep have enough resolution to do that
and we didn't realize I don't think we
realized until we were in to post really
far into it how far we could go that we
could go about a hundred and
seventy-five percent which is a lot
farther than we were originally told we
could do but what a meant it was if you
had a two shot you could zoom into a
single if you had a four shot you could
zoom into a two shot in post-production
so for for any take we were shooting
with two cameras and two cameras meant
not just to take not just to usable
takes but really for because you know
with zooming in and zooming out and post
you could really do a whole scene in
just one take and it takes a while to
kind of explain this to the actors and
really and again we didn't realize how
far we could take it until we really
started working with the colorist and
you know in the post-production people
but but it means you can get a lot of
coverage very quickly and again as long
as your actors are good and they're
doing the part and they're saying the
lines right which they weren't so so
that gave us a lot more opportunities in
post-production you know I mean there's
certain reasons you don't want to do
that but for the most part it gives you
a lot of options I mean these are tough
scenes to shoot and a lot of them are
long scenes and we have one scene that
towards the end of the movie it's
actually on paper it was a 19 page scene
and we tried to do it once all the way
through which is Mike and for those who
don't know it's like a 19-minute scene
you know
something that actually there's probably
50 minutes but still it's a long seat a
lot of dialogue and we got through one
take all the way through and everyone
was like we can't do this again we you
know we have to break it up into
segments which we kind of knew we would
ultimately do but we wanted to do kind
of one dry run through and but I'll tell
you footage from that original long take
is in the movie and a lot of it because
then on then once we broke it up then
all of a sudden the cameras weren't a
little bit different so we used coverage
from that first take and it is you get
something fresh from it of course the
cameras were bumping into actors I mean
it was you know those reasons you don't
want to do a 90 minute long take but and
that was a handheld scene yeah there
weren't that there wasn't there's not
much hand held in the movie but we kind
of use it in very specific places